this is happening yes it is hi guys I'm
here with Chester C hi yeah you're doing
great you're doing great
Chester and I and Jack berry record an
episode of not too deep that's very
Halloween based so make sure that you go
over to iTunes and SoundCloud and check
it out because there's a lot of stories
that are you okay with happening
you always say you have a small tour so
I'm sitting on my phone and while I'm
explaining that they should go over to
iTunes and salvo I just filled this
yeah Jeanette up yeah cuz I can see that
my legs are clearly shorter and then for
her have a longer torso like what are
you six sixes oh well I mean I mean I'm
right or my right guy should do stand-up
you should speaking of things that don't
make sense we're about to do a challenge
because right now we will both be
participating in the candy apple
challenge we will be bobbing for apples
in a tub of candy corn and what's gonna
happen is we will both go at the same
time I did I just burped really quietly
and then blew out my nose there's a
point system to this the first person to
ten points wins every apple is worth one
point however there are also in addition
to the apples in this tub some plastic
Halloween spiders and if you get a
spider a spider's worth two points so
we're gonna have to have our arms finder
back and we're gonna have to try and Bob
for apples and spiders until we get to
ten points how big are the spiders we're
going to find out I'm stronger am I
looking for those little spiders that
are also rings okay we're like
tarantulas you're looking for the things
in this tub that aren't apples or candy
corn okay I'm gonna take I'm gonna use
the same tactic I used last time when we
were killing babies well we shouldn't
give context to that gesture was a guest
here I'll not too deep before and it got
very competitive very quickly we did the
baby food challenge ahh
you shot me in the face dad did happen
QD replay and yes as you can see okay I
to start this yes the candy apple
challenge get to it breathing so hard
looking it ha 60s my your ass is right
here
why we're not there orange
eat [ __ ] mother okay thanks for watching
you guys if you enjoyed this you'll love
the podcast even more so make sure you
go over to iTunes or SoundCloud I listen
to not too deep with Chester C and Jack
Fairy and me and make sure you follow
Chester speak on all social media
platforms especially snapchat I like
snapchat alright and if you guys play
this game at home don't don't
it's not safe there's other ways of
doing this that are equally fun so many
things in my face hurt right now
yeah anyway thanks for watching guys
don't forget to Like and subscribe
you got like eye candy I don't know
don't touch me did you buy yourself the
first time no that's it that sounds
silly oh no I was very popular and I
wasn't like cool